rappelez vous il était l'un des premiers
habitants des yvelines à se faire
vacciner
après deux mois jean berthier 90 ans est
en forme
robot mois s'est mariée revêt en
garantie que les résidents des ehpad
était prioritaire dès l'arrivée des
vaccins en france dans cette maison de
repos à sartrouville 24 résidents sur 34
ont pu se faire vacciner
madeleine bonnet 94 ans a elle aussi
fait ses deux injections du vaccin
eiser ça s'est bien passé c'était bien
organisé a pas eu de problème on nous a
surveillé pendant quelques temps après
la vaccination
parfois jusque je souhaiterais que tout
le monde puisse avoir cette vaccination
y a que comme ça qu'on s'en sortir la
situation dans les ehpad a évolué avec
les vaccinations
dorénavant les visites ne sont plus
chronométrés et elles peuvent se faire
en chambre ça fait du bien
notre priorité c'est le bien-être des
résidents donc le b n est pas que
physique
le mien est moral est un peu en temps et
franchement ça se passe très bien
les résidents peuvent recevoir les
membres de la famille pour le déjeuner
les résidents peuvent sortir de
l'établissement également avec bien sûr
les mesures barrières à respecter le gel
hydroalcoolique le port du masque
mais oui les choses ont un peu changé
dans l'établissement un nouveau souffle
pour les résidents qui avait perdu le
moral ça m'a donné 10 en peluche voyez
tué son père maintenant on a
l'impression d'être incarcéré dans une
prison dans cet établissement des
familles ou des résidents ont d'abord
refusé la vaccination
ils ont finalement changé d'avis 32
résidents sur 34 devrait donc être
vaccinés dans cette étape